all the library is is a series of code
routines that you're going to reuse so
you rather than actually writing it
yourself you'll go and get it from
something that's already been written a
code library so that's where the idea
comes from you're reusing blocks of code
that have come from somewhere else
implementation lis you can do that in
many different ways I mean the simplest
thing is to think about a program so if
we think about a programming language
like C it's made up of a series of
functions so we might have a function
called int comp and that doesn't
actually have any parameters and that's
gonna call another function and we'll
call it printf and it's gonna say hello
computer file so that's a thing and this
is calling another function and when we
compile a C program or any programming
language the computer takes that code
and converts it into machine code and
then we execute that machine Coporation
whether we do that instantaneously for
interpreting or we compile it and
execute it later or a mixture of the two
immaterial for this point of view so
we've got to find this printer now we
could just have that defined in the
program straight after so it might
actually say so it might avoid printf
whatever the implementation of printf is
there that could be in our source file
as well and then that might use
something else and so they would all be
and so we could put all the code we need
for a program in one file we can file
that we convert it into one machine code
program and then we can use it that's
great except our program is going to get
bigger and bigger and bigger and bigger
and bigger and as you write more and
more programs you'll find that actually
every program is going to use printf and
every implementation of printf is going
to be the same so what you probably
would do is you would start off writing
a new program you say okay I need a
printf so you go and find a copy of the
previous printf and you cut and paste
the code from that one into your new one
and you carry on using it and and so on
so you could just do that but your
programs are still going to be huge long
things and finding
things inside there is going to be
complicated so what you start to do is
you say well actually I'm going to
collate various different routines there
you know I probably use printf a lot I
probably need something to read from the
keyboard scanf and C terms I probably
need something to do some file i/o and
so on then you get up with a series of
routines even pretty much going to use
in every program and so you callate them
together
and then when you write a program you
copy them all into that program so
that's what you could do if some of
these are used that often why are they
not embedded in the programming language
itself so why is it because you might
not need them so why does C not have a
print command
good question you'd have to ask Brian
Kernighan that actually was probably
around at the time there but I mean you
could you could take a sort of a purist
view of this is that it's printing part
of the programming language or is it
something you want to do with the
programming language and that C
demonstrates you don't need a print
command in your programming language
because we can implement it separately
so you can make an argument that you
don't need it in there you need your
programming language to have the basis
that you need to write everything you
wanted to write okay you want a library
to do image recognition or something do
you build that into your programming
language where do you stop you've got a
you've got a divide this somewhere let's
keep the language is simple and then it
makes it easier to write the compiler if
it's easy to write the compiler you
generally know it's relatively easier to
check the code works properly it's
simpler and particular if you think
about the computers that C was developed
on 64k was a luxury then it makes sense
to keep these things small so anyway
let's say we've gathered together some
routines we're using lots and lots
printf scanf file i/o those sort of
things we're going to use some of that
so we just collect them together and so
what we do perhaps is rather than
starting with a blank file and copying
them in we might actually put them all
into a file and then when we want to
start things while we copy that file and
just add our new code to the end of that
and things which is okay but it seems
the wrong way around to do it so what
you do is you modify your language to
actually have a way of including
that file rather than having all your
things in there you start off saying I
want to include something and then we'd
write comp routine as we had before and
all that include things says in C
particularly the hash in front of it is
copy the contents of that file as if it
was at this point in the program
it literally is doing text substitution
this way it's not doing anything more
than copying the text from one so rather
than reading the files from one father
reads from the other file and then
carries on it's like concatenate two
files together you compiler just that
and then it compiles the whole program
now that's not what C's doing but that's
the general idea behind a library we've
taken a set of routines that we use a
lot and generally we'll have them that
do various useful things that are
thematically similar and we've combined
them together and we've just we're just
going to reuse them so it's a reusable
library of code in the same way we can
have a library of books where you can go
and find particular information and you
get a specialist library my have a
science library a sort of fiction
library and so on and in the same way so
you might have a a sort of file i/o
library you might have a window GUI
library you might have an image
recognition library a networking library
and so on you could just include the
source file in there and let it work and
let the compiler compile it but actually
if you think about we're taking the same
a block of code and we're going to
convert it to machine code and that's a
deterministic process it's going to
produce the same machine care unless we
use a different compiler or we change
some of the options and so actually the
next stage of our sort of gathering
libraries is that you rather than
combining them or linking them together
at the source level this you sell Ashley
okay I'm going to go and compile all
these libraries to machine code ahead of
time then when I can pile up my program
I'm going to compile the new bits I've
just written and I'm going to link them
together with the stuff I've already
written there's the library code there's
the stuff that I've already compiled up
using every other program so if we take
something like printf which is in part
of the standard c library so it's a
library thing in there generally we will
use a pre compiled version of that
don't where we say hash include stdio.h
we're not including the source code for
printf we're including the source code
for that tells how to call printf it
just lets say you need to call it with
these parameters and then it will work
what actually happens is is in another
program called a linker which takes the
binary that's not even produced for that
the binary you've produced and combines
them together into a single binary
program in the right format that the
operating system needs so that you can
load them all in one go and run them and
it calls printf to do the things and
make it work so that's all that's all
the libraries there's a collection of
code routines that probably have been
compiled and then linked together to
form a complete static binary that can
be used now you don't have to do it that
way if we do it that way then we end up
with one binary which has all the
libraries copied into it that's what's
called static linking because it's just
one static file everything he needs in
there you can also do what's called a
dynamic linking which is a dynamic
library where basically all you're doing
there is he's delaying that linking
process till the program's loaded and
the eventually doing that is it you can
choose which one you load in and as long
as you know where to jump to and how to
update things to make things connect
together then you can make it work so
all the library really is whether it's a
static one or source library or dynamic
code library is a collection of code
routines that have been precompiled
often that you then link into your
program to make it work and it jumps
into that other bit of code and then
jumps back into yours they don't even
have to be written in the same language
so at some point inside printf it'll
probably call a bit of machine code to
actually make the operating system print
out these characters on screen and so on
see that this is also connected to the
same the bottom left side of this switch
and the bottom left side of this switch
and the bottom left side of that one and
so on all the way along we could follow
this trace until we get to the last one
it actually changed to the top right for
the last couple